لطالما تساءلنا كيف كان لدى داعش
الكثير من الذخيرة في الموصل
، وهذا واضح عندما ترى
مصانع الأسلحة التي كانت لديهم في
كل مكان كانوا يصنعون كل شيء
من قذائف الهاون الخدش
في مصنع واحد ، حتى أنهم كانوا يمتلكون
عربات همفي مزيفة مصنوعة من الخشب
كانوا يستخدمونها.  الشراك الخداعية
هذا يبدو أنه يجب أن يكون
نوعًا من
ورشة عمل الحرف اليدوية ، هناك شعور طفولي
في كل شيء ، لكن
هذا أيضًا ما يجعل الأمر أكثر
خطورة حتى أن تنظيم الدولة قد بدأ ببناء طائراته الخاصة
غير المصممة للهبوط في أي مكان ولكن
بدلاً من ذلك كان ينتحر.  القنابل
التي عثروا عليها داخل المنطقة الصناعية
في إحدى المناطق المستخدمة
للتصنيع جنبًا إلى جنب مع
بعض الكتيبات ، تم وضعها معًا بشكل بدائي إلى حد ما ،
لكن هذا
يتطلب مستوى معينًا من الخبرة والإبداع
والبراعة التي جمعوها معًا جميع
أنواع
الأجزاء المختلفة وحتى  استخدم الغراء لمحاولة إصلاح
بعض الأسلاك في مكانها